bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat sept mois après les
tueries de mohamed merah le sénat
examine cet après midi en séance le
projet loi qui doit permettre de
poursuivre les français auteurs d'actes
de terrorisme à l'étranger ou qui
partent à l'étranger pour s'y entraîner
au jihad
ce texte défendu par manuel valls le
ministre de l'intérieur octroie aux
tribunaux français
une universalité des compétences jusque
là pour que les tribunaux français jugé
bien ces français qui commettent des
actes de terrorisme à l'étranger
il fallait que les autorités des pays
étrangers concernés interpelle les
intéressés et mène à bien une procédure
d'extradition tout de suite notre
direction à l'hémicycle pour l'examen de
ce texte bonne science à tous mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre soit y
est le bienvenu dans cette assemblée ce
paisible par rapport à celle que vous
venez de quitter leur du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi relative à
la sécurité et à la lutte contre le
terrorisme dans la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur manuel valls
ce
monsieur le président monsieur le
président la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs nos démocraties
porte en elle des valeurs universelles
des valeurs qui ont contribué à élever
l'humanité a libéré les individus
apaiser les sociétés à permettre le
progrès le démocratie ont une ambition
pour elle même et pour le monde
cette ambition est critiquée ou
contestées elle fait aussi nous le
savons depuis longtemps l'objet d'
attaque violente et radicale la france
est particulièrement visée
ce n'est pas la première fois elle doit
donc logiquement impérativement se
défendre à la violence aveugle et lâche
à la terreur
elle doit opposer la force une force
pour arrêter pour juger pour punir la
force du droit
c'est cela le fondement même des
démocraties et c'est la raison du projet
de loi que j'ai l'honneur de vous
présenter aujourd'hui la france a déjà
été frappée dans sa chair par le
terrorisme
elle connaît l'enjeu et le prix de la
lutte qu'il implique
mais la france n'habitera jamais face
aux menaces le pays est confronté à un
terrorisme en constante mutation
il y a dix jours grâce à l'action
remarquable mené conjointement par la
sous direction antiterroriste de la
police judiciaire et la direction
centrale du renseignement intérieur sous
l'autorité de la justice
une cellule jihadiste d'une grande
dangerosité a été démantelé il y avait
urgence car cette cellule étaient déjà
passés à l'acte
le 19 septembre dernier contre une
épicerie une épicerie cacher à sarcelles
avec la probable intention de tuer elle
avait
les capacités les dernières perquisition
l'on établit et le procureur de paris
françois molins cela confirmer elle
avait la capacité de commettre le pire
s'il faut se féliciter de cette réussite
policière il ne faut céder à aucun
triomphalisme
nous devons rester en alerte et vigilant
car la menace est bien là le président
de la république et le premier ministre
ont rappelé leur détermination à
éradiquer ces cellules et ses filières à
lutter contre le terrorisme contre ceux
qui veulent s'en prendre à nos valeurs
qui veulent déstabiliser nos
institutions
en disant cela je mesure pleinement le
cadre dans lequel je veux inscrire mon
propos celui mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de la défense de l'intérêt
supérieur de notre pays
cette défense demande unité et cohésion
et je le souhaite
consensus je me trouve ici face à la
représentation nationale dans une
enceinte de la république et la
république doit être uni contre les
ennemis de la république le pays je le
disais a dû faire face au cours des
dernières décennies à des attaques
terroristes de nature diverse
en mars dernier il a été confronté un
constat tragique le retour après plus de
15 ans du terrorisme sur son sol mohamed
merah a tué à sept reprises avec des
objectifs précis
trois militaires trois de nos
compatriotes engagés pour la défense du
pays et quatre français juifs dont trois
enfants
ses motivations étaient sans ambiguïté
son parcours ne laisse planer aucun
doute
mohamed merah agi au nom d'une idéologie
de violence d'un islamisme radical qu'on
veut à la france qui on veut à notre
république notamment pour son engagement
en afghanistan et pour son idéal de
laïcité un islamisme radical qui porte
en lui la haine des juifs de tous les
juifs partout où ils se trouvent
parce qu'ils sont uniquement juifs les
méthodes d'action de mohamed merah sont
le résultat d'une préparation minutieuse
une préparation faite de contacts
nombreux de la fréquentation de sites
internet djihadistes d'un embrigadement
et d'un passage sans doute rapide par
les camps d'entraînement dans les zones
tribales pakistanaises est rien cette
affaire a révélé des failles dans
l'organisation de notre renseignement
des failles qu'il faut envisager avec
lucidité
si l'on veut se donner les moyens de les
corriger
dès ma prise de fonction j'ai demandé
que tous les enseignements
opérationnelle soit tiré sans fragiliser
bien évidemment notre enseignement et le
travail remarquable de nos agents afin
de procéder aux évolutions nécessaires
un rapport me sera remis prochainement
par deux inspecteurs généraux de la
police nationale qui sera transmis au
parlement
j'ai demandé qu'ils comprennent des
orientations précises pour améliorer le
pilotage des services territoriaux du
renseignement intérieur et renforcer la
capacité d'évaluation des parcours
individuels
j'ai souhaité qu'il insiste également
sur la coordination opérationnelle que
les services du renseignement intérieur
doivent nouer avec ceux chargés de
l'information générale et au delà
l'ensemble des services territoriaux de
police et de gendarmerie
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
menace terroriste est donc élevé elle
est d'abord et surtout lié aux ida isme
global elle vient notamment de
l'extérieur de zone géographique
clairement identifié cette menace porte
sur nos intérêts et nos ressortissants à
l'étranger
je pense bien évidemment devant vous à
nos compatriotes retenus comme otages
le président de la république a reçu
hier leurs familles pour leur faire part
du soutien de la nation
cette menace qui s'exprime à l'étranger
est également orienté je viens de le
dire faire notre territoire
le mali traverse une crise qui dépasse
les seules frontières
la présence de groupes terroristes dans
la zone sahélienne fait peser une menace
très grave sur les états de la région
sur leurs populations victimes
d'exactions et d'actes barbares
j'ai pu aborder cette question très
préoccupante en fin de semaine dernière
avec les autorités algériennes
la menace qui frappe le sel pèsent
également sur le reste du monde et sur
la france qui a été désigné par al qaïda
au maghreb islamique et le mouvement
pour l'unicité le jihad en afrique de
l'ouest comme un ennemi président de la
république a fait part de sa fermeté
avec ces groupes
il n'est pas question de discuter le
seul recours possible
c'est la force et le chef de l'état se
mobilise comme il l'a fait fin septembre
à la tribune des nations unies comme il
l'a répété il y a quelques jours l'an de
son déplacement en afrique pour
permettre au mali de retrouver son
intégrité territoriale
il est primordial d'éviter la
sanctuarisation de groupe terroriste
dans cette région
il faut agir pour que le mali et le sel
ne devienne pas l'afghanistan de
l'afrique
le vote de la résolution par le conseil
de sécurité des nations unies à
l'initiative de notre diplomatie est une
première étape importante la zone
afghano-pakistanaise demeure un lien
vous le savez de basculement et de
formation pour les candidats au djihad
au terrorisme dans des camps des
combattants volontaires venus souvent
d'europe reçoivent une formation
paramilitaire qui a pour objectif de
leur donner les moyens d'agir à leur
retour dans leur pays
c'est précisément ce que fit mohamed
merah ce qu'il fait avec un passeport
français avec la ferme intention
d'attaquer la france à son retour de la
péninsule arabique
al qaïda a également désigné la france
comme une cible prioritaire
après les etats-unis la france et visé
en raison du site des pratiques non
islamiques qui la caractérise la syrie
en guerre en guerre civile devient aussi
aujourd'hui
un terrain de motivation et de
préparation hozjan
si les printemps arabes ont été porteurs
de liberté pour les peuples et l'espoir
démocratique pour le plus grand nombre
ils ont aussi introduit des facteurs
d'instabilité la coopération avec ces
pays doit être aujourd'hui renforcée il
s'agit en effet de faire face aux visées
de groupes ultras radicaux qui est en
leur activité certains soutenant
ouvertement le djihadisme et pouvant
directement ou indirectement opérer en
france et je ne vous cache pas notre
difficulté pour établir cette
coopération avec un certain nombre de
ces pays au delà de la géographie il ya
également le cyberespace internet est
devenu un domaine à part entière où se
déploie le terrorisme un domaine où la
propagande l'endoctrinement la formation
idéologique et les mises en relation
logistique se perd entre individus
impliqués dans les différentes mouvances
terroristes aux quatre coins de la
planète
au fond ils peuvent ensemble faire vivre
une idéologie de haine la menace est
certes alimenté depuis l'extérieur mais
elle liens de plus en plus de
l'intérieur ce fut d'ailleurs le cas
pour les attentats du 11 septembre 2001
aux états unis ceux de madrid en 2004 ou
de londres en 2005 parmi d'autres
exemples c'est une stratégie explicite
des groupes djihadistes d'encourager et
de favoriser des circuits de formation
idéologique et paramilitaires cours ce
lien intense entre l'extérieur et
l'intérieur propre d'ailleurs à notre
monde globalisé est un facteur
d'aggravation de la menace un facteur
dont il faut prendre l'entière mesure la
menace qui se développe sur notre
territoire peut être le fait de groupes
d'individus parfois convertis de fraîche
date le cellules plus ou moins étendues
comme l'étaient déjà
khaled kelkal et ses complices ou le
gang de roubaix
elle est également le fait d' individus
auto-radicalisés ces individus et ces
groupes ont souvent commun d'avoir
réalisé des séjours d'entraînement ou de
projeter de le faire et de fréquenter
sur internet les sites islamistes
radicaux
des sites qui leur permettent de devenir
de véritables apprentis terroristes
ces individus véritable ennemi de
l'intérieur reprennent une menace
diffuse qui demande donc un travail de
surveillance lourd et méticuleux cette
menace terroriste nouvelle n'est souvent
au sein de nos quartiers populaires les
basculements individuelle vers l'islam
radical peuvent prolonger un passé
délinquant dans une démarche se dorer
nantes crise une démarche parfois
commencé en détention voilà sortis de la
prison
ce risque justifie une attention
particulière aux parcours individuels et
le développement mise en oeuvre par la
garde des sceaux de l'aumônerie
musulmane au sein des établissements
pénitentiaires
il nécessite également une étroite
coopération bien évidemment des services
de renseignement avec l'administration
pénitentiaire
de manière plus générale c'est
l'habitude du recours à la violence et
la dépersonnalisation de la souffrance
infligée à autrui propre à beaucoup de
comportements délinquants qui
fournissent un ancrage favorable au
basculement vers le terrorisme
s'y ajoute un antisémitisme virulent que
nous devons combattre de toutes nos
forces et l'instrumentalisation des
conflits du proche et du moyen orient
très souvent aussi le basculement est
favorisée par l' influence néfaste des
discours d' imams autoproclamés le
processus de radicalisation peut être
rapide
quelques mois à peine comme viennent de
le démontrer les dernières
interpellations les individus souvent
jeunes endoctrinés bascule alors dans la
violence et passe ou peuvent passer à
l'acte beaucoup de musulmans de notre
pays et tout particulièrement ceux issus
de la deuxième la troisième génération
qui peuvent douter de leur identité sont
exposés aujourd'hui à l'interprétation
salafistes de l'islam
c'est une interprétation dangereuse qui
n'est pas celle de leurs parents ou de
leur pays d'origine
elle peut porter en elle l'idée que la
violence est légitime contre les
supposés ennemis de l'islam
et qu'elle passe par le sacrifice de sa
personne comme moyen d'action c'est un
regard lucide nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui sur la réalité que nous
connaissons dans notre pays aux côtés de
ces individus et cellules peuvent se
trouver des structures à but terroriste
qui s'étendent sur l'ensemble du
territoire
l'action efficace des services ainsi
permis le démantèlement en mars 2012 du
groupe forsane alizza structurés à
l'échelle de l'hexagone qui se prépare
est sans doute à des actions d'envergure
sur notre territoire
le terrorisme qui menace sur notre sol
est liée aux yade mais n'est pas liée
qu'à cela
il existe d'autres manifestations
violentes plus anciennes je ne veux pas
établir de vaines hiérarchie entre les
terreurs tout ce qu'ils veulent
déstabiliser notre état doivent
s'attendre à une réponse d'une même
fermeté
les ressortissants étrangers qui se
trouvent sur notre territoire et qui
veulent s'en prendre à nos institutions
feront l'objet comme la loi le permet
d'expulsion et vous pouvez être certain
de ma totale détermination dans ce
domaine l'organisation terroriste basque
eta annoncé le 21 octobre 2011
l'abandon définitif des actions armées
il faut voir dans cette déclaration
la conséquence d'une coopération
anti-terroriste efficace sur le long
terme
depuis près de trente ans entre les
services français et espagnols pour
autant là aussi la situation appelle
notre extrême vigilance et notre fermeté
pas naïve tu es dans ce domaine là non
plus les conclusions du sommet
franco-espagnol du 10 octobre reflète
cette position que j'avais moi-même
rappelait en mai dernier lors d'un
déplacement à madrid et dans la
continuité
la seule issue possible est la
dissolution totale de letea c'est un
préalable
sans cela aucun aucune éventualité de
dialogue n'est possible
la république doit d'ailleurs faire
preuve d'une fermeté équivalente en
corse où le recours à la violence
terroriste reste une tentation prégnante
la violence tout court comme
malheureusement les faits d'aujourd'hui
le démon
cette violence nuit gravement au
développement économique et social de
l'île
les groupes qui se réclament ou qui s'en
réclament
et qui pratique le plasticage masque
parfois mal dans leur objectif la
poursuite d'intérêts économiques peu
avouables et leur proximité troubles
avec les réseaux délinquants de droit
commun en démocratie mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
l'action politique ne peut frayé avec la
violence jamais ce qui prône la lutte
armée ne pourront s'asseoir à la table
de la république
ce panel de la menace djihadisme zone
géographique identifiée radicalisme dans
le quartier ultra droite identitaire
ultragauche violente en montre les
évolutions les menaces d'hier ne sont
pas celles d'aujourd'hui sans doute
encore moins celle de demain ce constat
souligne la nécessité permanente d'une
adaptation de notre dispositif pour
garantir et c'est évidemment l objectif
que nous partageons tous la sécurité de
nos compatriotes
avec ce projet de loi nous ne répondons
pas dans l'urgence nous garantissons une
constance dans l'efficacité de notre
lutte antiterroriste
l'intervention législative doit rendre
notre droit plus fort nous rende plus
fort et une démocratie qui s'appuie sur
le droit d'en faire preuve d'unité
lorsqu'il s'agit de faire face à des
individus et des groupes
ils ne respectent aucune règle l'unité
de la nation passent d'abord par le
refus catégorique bien évidemment de
toute stigmatisation
le combat que nous menons est celui de
tous les français de tous les démocrates
je tiens à rappeler avec force par
exemple combien l'islamisme radical est
une idéologie de violence qui est le
fait d'individus qui offensent l'islam
qui n'ont rien à voir avec l'islam
l'islam est une religion qui porte en
elle comme d'autres un message de
tolérance et de dialogue et l'islam de
france a toute sa place en france et
dans la république la lutte contre le
radicalisme autres ceux qui prêchent la
haine doit nous mobiliser
elle doit mobiliser la communauté
nationale tous les français et donc tous
les français où tous les citoyens de
confession musulmane qui je les entends
comme vous
condamne à l'unisson les actes commis ce
projet de loi est utile à la république
aux français utiles aux services de
sécurité utile aux magistrats qui
quotidiennement lutte contre le
terrorisme le gouvernement précédent
avait déposé le 11 avril 2012 à la suite
des attentats de montauban et de
toulouse
un projet sous l'impulsion de votre
désormais collègue michel mercier nous
l'avons intégré à notre réflexion sans
pour autant reprendre toutes les
dispositions dont certaines nous
paraissait outre quelques questions de
constitutionnalité ne pas répondre aux
besoins des services anti terroristes
mais bien entendu j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire à michel mercier
je reste disposée à toute amélioration
du texte le dispositif français de
prévention et de répression du
terrorisme est le fruit d'une expérience
de 25 ans
dès 1986 la pratique administrative la
loi et la jurisprudence ont forgé les
instruments performants
la france s'est dotée d'un dispositif
judiciaire spécifique à forte composante
préventives dont le pivot est la
répression de l'association de
malfaiteurs à caractère terroriste
il maintient le juge au coeur de la
lutte antiterroriste tout en instaurant
un équilibre entre l'efficacité de la
lutte contre ce phénomène et des
libertés publiques
la france a progressivement fait évoluer
ce dispositif en l'adaptant sans cesse à
l'émergence de nouvelles menaces
aujourd'hui il faut donc à la fois
préserver cet acquis et consolider son
efficacité d'ensemble c'est l'esprit qui
a présidé à l'élaboration de ce projet
de loi
nous avons pris le temps de la réflexion
de la concertation nous avons tiré les
conclusions du passé étudier les retours
d'expérience nous avons aussi analyser
les différentes propositions qui avaient
pu être fait sans esprit partisan cas il
ne peut pas y avoir d'esprit partisan
quand il s'agit de la lutte contre le
terrorisme ce travail je les menées en
étroite coopération avec la garde des
sceaux
je suis convaincu que la lutte contre le
terrorisme comme la lutte contre la
délinquance ne peut être efficace
que si elle associe pleinement les
ministères de la justice et de
l'intérieur
cette complémentarité entre les services
de renseignement la police et les
juridictions spécialisées en matière de
terrorisme est l'une des forces est
l'une des forces du modèle français et
nous devons tous préserver cette
dynamique
c'est pourquoi avec christiane taubira
nous avons réuni des représentants de la
direction centrale du renseignement
intérieur de la police judiciaire et du
parquet antiterroriste
notre objectif était simple favoriser
l'expression commune des besoins de ceux
qui font quotidiennement face au
terrorisme qui en mesurent les risques
et en connaissent les évolutions ce
projet de loi le fruit donc de ce
travail commun nous avons retenu ce que
les praticiens estimé utile selon ils
ont concrètement besoin toute surenchère
inutile a été évité il ne s'agit pas
d'un texte de réaction non plus en
matière de terrorisme peut être encore
plus que dans d'autres domaines
l'émotion est un mauvais guide pour le
législateur s'est talabot ration en
partenariat avec le ministère de la
justice est également me semble-t-il une
garantie celle d'un équilibre entre
efficacité de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et préservation comme je le
soulignais de nos libertés publiques
face aux risques terroristes les vaines
polémiques n'ont pas leur place
je suis très heureux de présenter ce
texte d'abord au sénat parce que je
connais la sagesse de votre assemblée
cette volonté d'une réponse unique à
guider l'élaboration du projet loi
j'espère vivement qu'elle viendra
également sur l'examen à ce stade
monsieur le rapporteur chaque jacques
mézard je ne peux que saluer le travail
très constructif que vous avez déjà
menées et à la lecture des débats qui
ont eu lieu mercredi dernier je crois
monsieur le président cher jean pierre
sueur que l'esprit qui anime votre
commission des lois sur ce thème est le
même que le mien
l'unité républicaine nous souhaitons que
ce texte soit un texte de mobilisation
mobilisation de la représentation
nationale bien évidemment mais surtout
mobilisation de toute la société
française contre ceux qui cherchent tout
qui chercheraient à lui imposer une
volonté qui n'est pas la sienne et qu'il
ne sera jamais la sienne
ce projet doit se veut pragmatique donc
il s'appuie sur deux volets un volet
préventif qui permet notamment un autre
système de renseignement de mieux
détecter identifier appréhender la
menace un volet répressif qui permet de
sanctionner plus efficacement les
activités terroristes
le volet préventif contenues dans
l'article 1 consiste à proroger les
dispositions temporaire de la loi du 23
janvier 2006 relative à la lutte contre
le terrorisme
des dispositions qui au fil du temps ont
fait la preuve de leur utilité pour les
services spécialisés et les magistrats
et les magistrats en charge de
l'antiterrorisme
les contrôles d'identité préventifs dans
des gares routières ou ferroviaires et
sur des portions de lignes notamment
dans les trains à grande vitesse
transfrontalier doivent être favorisés
les dispositions permettant de ne pas
enfermer l'action contrôle les services
de police dans un délai trop court sont
source d'efficacité opérationnelle elles
doivent donc être maintenue elles ont
notamment permis l'augmentation je veux
le souligner du nombre de patrouilles
mixtes à bord des trains internationaux
sur les liaisons ferroviaires avec
l'allemagne la belgique l'espagne la
suisse ou l'italie ce qui a représenté
une avancée très positive car certaines
lignes ferroviaires par leur caractère
symbolique ont pu constituer ou
constituent des cibles d'action pour
certains réseaux terroristes
l'accès préventif les services de
renseignement aux données techniques
recueillies dans les communications
électroniques ou lors de la consultation
de sites internet
et là aussi un outil tout à fait
fondamental il permet notamment de
vérifier pour couper de manière continue
et compris dans l'urgence les
informations recueillies à titre
préventif
c'est le lot quotidien d'ailleurs de
tout service de renseignement ainsi sont
accumulés étayer ou au contraire écarter
les soupçons portant sur des personnes
ou des réseaux potentiellement dangereux
cette activité s'effectue sous le
contrôle préalable une personnalité
qualifiée directement subordonné à une
autorité administrative indépendante
le modèle garantit la fluidité et la
judiciarisation des informations
accumulées
dès que l'effet détecter justifie
l'ouverture
d'un cadre d'un enquête l'analyse des
données de connexion ainsi permis au
cours des derniers mois d'identifier par
exemple les administrateurs d'un site
islamiste dont l'objectif était
notamment le recrutement de candidats au
djihad
ce la base des informations recueillies
une procédure judiciaire a pu être
ouverte et le principal administrateur
du site a été arrêté ekoué internet les
réseaux sociaux ou twitter sont devenus
des lieux de propagation de la haine des
lieux où les propos les plus odieux se
diffuse nous les projets les plus
ignobles peuvent se préparer dans ce
domaine il nous faut être
particulièrement mobilisés et savoir
apporter les réponses précises solide
sur le plan juridique qui conviennent le
gouvernement propose de proroger une
dernière fois je sais que vous y êtes
attentifs les dispositions de l'article
6 une dernière fois car il me semble
désormais opportun de mettre à profit ce
délai le parlement il sera évidemment
étroitement associés pour repenser
l'articulation et faire converger ces
dispositions avec celle de la loi du 10
juillet 1991 relatif au secret des
correspondances émises par la voie des
communications électroniques
plusieurs amendements sont prévus à cet
effet
cette évolution s'inscrira également à
la suite du livre blanc celui ci définit
gras définira les priorités stratégiques
et opérationnelles propres à assurer la
sécurité des français
c'est dans ce cadre renouvelé qu'il faut
aussi mener une réflexion sereine et
approfondie l'accès à certains
traitements automatisés administratif
carte nationale d'identité passeport ou
encore permis de conduire permet aux
services spécialisés de procéder à de
multiples vérifications et de contrôler
par exemple si un titre d'identité
saisie est vrai ou faux il permet
également dans une démarche
d'anticipation de suivre les
déplacements internationaux d'individus
notamment ceux suspectés d'islamisme
radical mais pas seulement
d'une manière plus générale ces
consultations de fichiers participe de
l'activité permanente de documentation
des services qui sont habilités pour
être efficace notre droit doit être
clair
c'est pourquoi j'avais proposé la
ratification qui aurait permis que le
code de sécurité intérieure acquiert
valeur liquidative votre commission des
lois monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur a estimé qu'elle avait besoin
de davantage de temps pour examiner ce
code
je l'entends parfaitement le code de
sécurité intérieure fera toutefois il
nous verrons au fur et à mesure de
débats l'objet d'un amendement à
l'assemblée nationale le volet préventif
vise donc la continuité à renforcer
l'efficacité de la lutte antiterroriste
il est complété et j'en terminerai par
là d'un volet répressif
la législation française en matière de
lutte contre le terrorisme est
particulièrement complète je le
soulignais elle comporte toutefois une
insuffisance à laquelle seule la loi
peut répondre saisie ou poursuivre et de
condamner les personnes qui participent
à l'étranger un acte terroriste ou à une
association de malfaiteurs en relation
avec une entreprise terroriste
mais qui n'ont commis aucun acte
délictuel délictueux en france
concrètement cette évolution permettra
de poursuivre pénalement et nous avons
vu tous de la nécessité
les ressortissants français qui se
rendraient à l'étranger pour y suivre
des travaux d'endoctrinement ou pour
intégrer des camps d'entraînement ses
ressortissants français pourront être
poursuivis j insiste alors même qu'ils
n'auront pas encore commis d'actes
répréhensibles sur le territoire
national et c'est une avancée importante
sinon décisive la neutralisation
judiciaire pj a dit revenant ou tentant
de revenir sur notre sol est en effet
j'en suis convaincu un impératif il ya
une continuité territoriale de la menace
il faut donc une continuité territoriale
des poursuites en matière de répression
ce projet de loi propose enfin dans son
article 3 d'améliorer nos procédures
d'expulsion visant les ressortissants
étrangers que j'évoquais il ya un
instant tenant des discours radicaux ou
soutenant le terrorisme
je veux le répéter pour que les choses
soient claires ce qui se trouve sur le
territoire de la république avec
l'intention de lui ni de lui nuire
doivent être expulsé sans ménagement
la menace est là elle est diverse
nous devons comme chaque fois par le
passé la regarder en face lucidement
avec détermination sans jamais céder à
la crainte il n'y a pas de raisons à
cela
différents gouvernements les différentes
majorités qui ont été confrontés au
terrorisme ont agi avec la même
détermination
les françaises et les français doivent
savoir que tout est mis en oeuvre pour
garantir leur sécurité
elle est logiquement naturellement
aujourd'hui la priorité du président de
la république et celle du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs en
vous présentant aujourd'hui ce projet de
loi je vous invite à donner un autre
pays à la france à la république
une entière capacité d'action elle est
nécessaire pour la défense de ce qu'elle
est pour la défense de ce qui fait les
fondements mêmes de ce que nous sommes
et tout simplement pour la défense de la
démocratie
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
maintenant et au rapporteur de la
commission des lois le président jacques
mézard
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre vous avez employé
les mots qui conviennent dans un
discours marquant une volonté politique
quand la république est menacée c'est le
cas dans la période actuelle les
méthodes du terrorisme évolue pas son
fondement contraire à ce qui fait
l'essence de l'humanité le terrorisme et
de toutes les époques et chers collègues
il renaît constamment de l'expression du
fanatisme monstres issus de tous les
obscurantismes et croissants au gré des
misères des peuples
chaque renaissance du terrorisme est
vécu comme la survenance d'un mâle
nouveau en réalité les peuples en peu de
mémoire qui se souvient aujourd'hui des
attentats anarchistes de la fin du 19e
siècle qui se souvient que la troisième
république a perdu deux de ses président
sadi carnot et paul doumer
il n'est de régime auquel le terrorisme
ne s'est attaqué et il en est ainsi
depuis la période historique
la violence est rarement légitime et
bien de justes causes l'emportèrent sans
y recourir
gandhi en fut l'exemple mais elle est
encore plus illégitime
lorsqu'elle s'en prend à des régimes
fondés sur la volonté du peuple et la
démocratie revendications territoriales
revendications sociales ou plus
fréquemment fanatisme religieux
le terrorisme s'en prend au fondement
même de nos sociétés démocratiques
qu'il s'agisse de fondamentalisme
religieux ou de letea ou en corse du sud
des assassinats dont celui du préfet
erignac que nous ne saurions oublier et
l'actualité d'aujourd'hui rappelle
encore
ces méthodes absolument ignobles mais le
processus est similaire et nous devons
combattre ce fléau en oublions pas qu au
delà des actes ignobles visant des
personnalités se sont plus souvent des
citoyens anonymes qui tombe victimes de
cette barbarie
les moyens utilisés par les terroristes
évolué avec la société
aujourd'hui l'utilisation de nouveaux
moyens de communication de déplacement à
changer la donne nos sociétés doivent
adopter des moyens de lutte adéquat la
menace vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
ministre ne vient pas seulement de
l'extérieur
elle a aussi gangrené l'intérieur quels
sont les objectifs d'une politique
antiterroriste dans un pays démocratique
donnés les moyens humains matériels et
législatif aux services compétents et
aux magistrats pour prévenir le
terrorisme et le réprimer appliquer la
loi de la république sans aucune
faiblesse et vous l'avez dit utiliser la
force si nécessaire
aucune concession aucun laxisme mais
aussi parce que nous sommes une belle
démocratie respecter les principes
fondamentaux de notre droit et les
libertés fondamentales de nos
concitoyens cet équilibre
il peut il doit trouver le plus large
consensus
c'est l'intérêt national vous n'osiez
avait appelé monsieur le ministre je ne
suis pas choqué personnellement que
l'exposé des motifs du présent projet de
loi reprennent littéralement certains
éléments du projet de loi déposé en
avril dernier par monsieur le ministre
mercier il est des constats dont la
pertinence perdure quels que soient les
changements de majorité
ceci étant dit le texte du projet de loi
qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui présente
quelques différences notables avec le
texte précédent
il vient en urgence pour une raison
évidente qui ne saurait échapper à
personne
ce projet inclut la question de la
prorogation des dispositions temporaire
institué par la loi du 23 janvier 2006
disposition expirant le 31 décembre 2012
est considéré comme indispensable vous
l'avez aussi rappelé par les services
compétents
qu'elles soient prorogés ou pérenniser
il fallait que la procédure législative
soit respectée madame trendel il tenait
à juste titre c'est fait le texte du
gouvernement précédent n'incluait pas
cette question de la loi de 2006 et si
vous étiez resté aux commandes de
l'exécutif il eût fallu un nouveau texte
en urgence de toute façon autre
différence notable le texte précédent
créé en droit pénal quatre nouvelles
incriminations ce qui pouvait d'ailleurs
peut-être expliquer qu'il soit porté par
le ministre de la justice
alors que le texte qui nous est soumis
procès de monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre
par ce texte vous avez manifestement
poursuivi un objectif principal donner
les moyens nécessaires aux
professionnels en charge de la lutte
contre le terrorisme en évitant de créer
d'accumuler de nouveaux textes pénaux
dont l'utilité n'aurait pas été
démontrée nous ne pouvons que partager
avec conviction ce choix ayant toujours
considéré que l'accumulation de
nouvelles lois pénales
à chaque vague médiatique ne relevait
pas d'une approche raisonnée de la
construction de notre édifice juridique
nous sommes heureux de cette nouvelle
approche elle correspond à ce que nous
avons constamment soutenu si je puis
résumé que nous ont dit les
professionnels en charge de la lutte
contre le terrorisme
quand l'état l'arsenal législatif dont
il dispose qui est l'oeuvre de
gouvernements successifs et
diverses majorité est relativement
complet que subsiste une lacune
concernant la difficulté à poursuivre
devant les juridictions pénales
françaises
les français ayant commis à l'étranger
un délit en lien avec le terrorisme par
exemple la participation à des camps
d'entraînement terroristes votre projet
de loi par son article 2 va combler
cette lacune sans créer une nouvelle
incrimination par extension du texte
relatif à l'association de malfaiteurs
les mêmes professionnels ont exprimé
clairement que les dispositions des
articles 3 6 9 de la loi du 23 janvier
2006 leur était très utile
la loi du 10 juillet 1991 en l'état ne
permettait pas ne permettant pas de
couvrir totalement toutes les questions
à ce stade il convient de rappeler
rapidement les grands traits de notre
dispositif anti-terroriste qui est selon
les praticiens que nous avons entendu
relativement bien construit efficace
d'un point de vue organise
organisationnel bien qu'en principe les
juridictions locales et le tribunal de
grande instance de paris dispose d'une
compétence concurrente dans ce domaine
la poursuite des actes terroristes et en
pratique pas de droits mais en pratique
centralisée au niveau de la juridiction
parisienne
celle ci comprend en effet un pôle
antiterroriste au sein du parquet au
sein du siège regroupant des juges
spécialisés
nous avons entendu monsieur kristen pour
le parquet monsieur trévidic pour les
juges d'instruction et nous savons que
le jugement des crimes terroristes
relève d'une cour d'assises spécialisée
du point de vue de la loi pénale
le terrorisme est définie par la
combinaison d'un crime ou d'un délit de
droit commun et d'une entreprise
individuelle ou collective ayant pour
but de troubler gravement l'ordre public
par l'intimidation ou la terreur surtout
l'efficacité du dispositif français
reposent sur l'infraction d'association
de malfaiteurs en vue de préparer des
actes terroristes
entrée en vigueur après la promulgation
de la loi du 22 juillet 1996
c'est cette infraction qui permet en
effet de poursuivre facilement des
personnes dès l'instant qu'elles ont
accompli des actes les associant à
d'autres en vue de la préparation
d'actes de terrorisme
enfin le dispositif anti-terroriste
repose sur des instruments spéciaux dont
disposent les services enquêteurs dont
la sous direction antiterroriste de la
police judiciaire l'unité de
coordination de la lutte antiterroriste
et la direction centrale du
renseignement intérieur sous le contrôle
de l'autorité judiciaire
ou dans certains cas en amont de
l'intervention de celle-ci s'agit de la
possibilité de réaliser des saisies et
des perquisitions de sonoriser et de
filmer des véhicules et des lieux de
capter des données informatiques en
amont de la phase judiciaire les
services essentiellement la dcr y
dispose des outils dont les adopter la
loi du 23 janvier 2006 ce sont ces
outils dont l'article 1 du projet de loi
propose de proroger l'existence jusqu'au
1er janvier 2015 alors que sans cette
prolongation il deviendrait caduc à la
fin de l'année il s'agit de la
possibilité de demander aux opérateurs
de communications électroniques et aux
fournisseurs d'accès internet les
données de connexion des utilisateurs
elles concernent ensuite les fameuses
fadettes c'est à dire les factures
détaillées
il peut s'agir enfin d'une demande de
géolocaliser de géolocalisation d'une
personne ces données de connexion
aujourd'hui constitue un des principaux
outils dont se sert les services
enquêteurs pour comprendre le
fonctionnement des cellules au réseau
soupçonné de préparer des actes
terroristes
le deuxième instrument vous avez rappelé
son utilité monsieur le ministre ce sont
les contrôles d'identité dans les trains
internationaux
enfin les services de renseignement ont
accès à des fichiers administratifs afin
de déterminer l'identité complète d'une
personne de vérifier une identité ou
encore de retrouver la trace de
personnes surveillées partis à
l'étranger et qui demande un passeport
ces dispositifs sont étroitement
encadrés chaque utilisateur devant être
abily
s'il y a eu des dérives et il y en a eu
nous le savons même pas très fréquente
d'après les acteurs que nous avons
entendu mais nous savons qu'il y en a eu
y compris du côté de la justice elles ne
sont pas imputables au cadre législatif
mais concerne des cas où certains
services semblent s'être affranchi de ce
cadre légal comme nous en avons pu avoir
connaissance dans certaines affaires
récentes
je vous propose donc d'accepter cette
prorogation qui me paraît plus
pertinente qu une pérennisation en
l'état laquelle nécessite un bilan est
vraisemblablement et même certainement
une refonte avec les dispositions de la
loi du 10 juillet 1991 et il faudra le
faire en second lieu l'article 2
complète le code pénal afin comme je
l'indiquais de prévoir l'application de
la loi pénale française aux crimes et
délits qualifié d' actes de terrorisme
commis par un français hors du
territoire de la république
aujourd'hui notre arsenal législatif
laisse subsister cette lacune
impossibilité pratique de poursuivre et
de condamner un français qui sans
commettre aucun délit sur le territoire
national participe à l'étranger à une
infraction à caractère terroriste
cette difficulté mes chers collègues
elle résulte des règles gouvernant
l'application de la loi pénale française
dans l'espace car elle n'est applicable
à une infraction commise à l'étranger
qu'à plusieurs conditions cumulatives
qu'il s'agisse d'un crime ou d'un délit
la compétence de notre loi pénale
française est subordonnée à deux
conditions
l'auteur de l'infraction doit posséder
la nationalité française le jour du
déclenchement des poursuites
enfin en vertu de la règle dite non bis
in idem
aucune poursuite ne peut être exercée
contre une personne justifiant qu'elle a
été jugée définitivement à l'étranger
pour les mêmes faits ensuite s'agissant
des délits deux conditions
supplémentaires sont requises
les faits doivent être punis par la
législation du pays où ils ont été
commis et la poursuite ne peut être
exercée qu'à la requête du ministère
public et être précédée d'une plainte de
la victime ou d'une dénonciation
officielle
par l'autorité du pays où le fai a été
commis donc si ces conditions ne
ternissent pas d'engager des poursuites
à l'encontre de l'un de nos
ressortissants
elles peuvent en revanche compliqué
l'ouverture d'une procédure concernant
un français soupçonné d'un délit commis
hors du territoire national car il est
très improbable que les pays qui tolère
des camps d'entraînement sur leur
territoire répondent à l'exigence de
réciprocité d'incrimination et procède à
une dénonciation officielle
certes la qualification d'association de
malfaiteurs permet de couvrir des actes
commis à l'étranger dès lors qu'ils sont
connexes à d'autres faits en relation
avec une entreprise terroriste
kobe en france les uns comme les autres
formes selon notre jurisprudence
un tout indissociable mais il peut
arriver qu aucun acte préparatoire n'ait
été commis en france soit que l'auteur
ait quitté depuis longtemps notre
territoire soit qu'il se soit rendu à
l'étranger pour des motifs qu'il n'est
pas facile de mettre en relation avec
une entreprise terroriste par exemple
des motifs familiaux l'évolution des
modes opératoires en matière de
terrorisme rend ces situations de plus
en plus fréquentes
la disposition qui est proposé dans ce
texte dans ce projet permet d'écarter
non seulement comme tel est déjà le cas
pour les crimes l'exigence de
réciprocité d'incrimination de dépôt
d'une plainte ou dénonciation mais aussi
la condition relative à l'absence de
condamnation pour les mêmes faits du
principe non bis in idem
seule demeure la condition de
nationalité française du mis-en-cause
cette évolution est cohérente avec la
compétence déjà reconnu par l'article
113 du code pénal sans mention d'aucune
explique exception à la loi pénale
française
l'infraction commise à l'étranger
susceptibles de compromettre gravement
notre or public est traité de la même
manière qu'une infraction commise en
france la mesure couvre un champ plus
large que celle qui avait été envisagé
dans le précédent projet de loi présenté
en mai 2012 qui d'une part
ne concernait que la participation à
l'étranger à l'association de
malfaiteurs en lien avec une entreprise
terroriste et d'autre part ne prévoyez
de déroger qu'à la condition de
réciprocité d'incrimination et à celles
liées à la dénonciation officielle par
l'autorité du pays où l'acte a été
commis
en revanche contrairement à ce projet de
loi elle ne vise que les ressortissants
français et non les personnes résidant
habituellement sur le territoire
français après la réunion de la
commission de ce matin je pense que nous
pourrons trouver une formule qui
contentera tout le monde
sur ce point le projet de loi n'a pas
aussi à ce stade retenue les nouvelle
incrimination spécifique proposée par le
précédent projet dans des conditions
d'urgence que nous comprenons mais qui
pour nous manquer de recul sans doute
avec l'absence d' évaluation approfondie
du thym du droit en vigueur par rapport
je dirai à la réaction est à l'urgence
si le cadre juridique actuel est très
complet il peut néanmoins mes chers
collègues être appelée à évoluer dans le
respect des principes et libertés
constitutionnellement garanties afin de
répondre à une menace dont les formes
sont à la fois multiple émouvante
l'efficacité de cette lutte dépend aussi
pour beaucoup des pratiques des acteurs
de la lutte contre le terrorisme et nous
savons des affaires récentes et en
particulier celle qui a beaucoup remué
nos concitoyens au printemps dernier
montre que l'enjeu porte principalement
sur le moment où les magistrats sont
saisis par les services de renseignement
d'une affaire cette judiciarisation ne
doit intervenir ni trop tôt afin que les
éléments recueillis soit suffisamment
établis pour constituer l'infraction ni
trop tard afin d'empêcher l'attentât
cet égard la faculté de poursuivre plus
facilement les infractions commises à
l'étranger ne doit empêcher ni de
remonter les filières ni de collecter
les informations nécessaires sur les
intéressés en tout état de cause
l'extension de compétence de la loi
pénale prévue par le nouvel article 113
13 n'exonère rappaz les services
spécialisés de réunir les preuves du
comportement délictueux à l'étranger
l'article 3 du texte proposé d'encadrer
le délai dont dispose la commission
départementale d'expulsion pour se
prononcer il a eu raison monsieur le
ministre de dire que dans ces cas là la
république doit expulser sans faiblesse
cette commission doit donner un avis non
conformes
nous savons aujourd'hui que lorsqu'il y
à un renvoi de séance à la demande de
l'étranger la commission se prononce
très largement après le délai d'un mois
qui lui est pourtant imposer le
gouvernement a proposé qu'il soit prévu
dans la loi qu un dégré avec un décret
fixe un délai au delà duquel la vie sera
réputée rendu nous avons considéré qu'il
s'agit ici d'une atteinte certes
justifiée par la sauvegarde de l'ordre
public à la liberté individuelle et que
cela relève plutôt du législateur nous
avons donc adopté à la commission des
lois un amendement d'inscrire dans la
loi le délai d'un mois et de prévoir un
autre un délai d'un mois supplémentaire
si l'étranger a demandé le renvoi pour
un motif légitime
vous allez bien voulu convenir monsieur
le ministre que notre demande de la
commission relative à la suppression de
l'article 5 était entendu par vous même
dont acte je pense que c'était tout à
fait logique de proposer cette
suppression compte tenu du délai très
court que nous avions
quant à l'article 6 il tend à autoriser
le gouvernement à prendre une ordonnance
pour inclure dans le code de la sécurité
intérieure les dispositions de la loi du
6 mars 2000 douze relatives à
l'établissement d'un contrôle des armes
modernes simplifiée et préventif cette
loi doit modifier à compter du 6
septembre 2013 certains articles du code
de la défense dont une partie fut
transféré à compter du 1er 2012 au code
de la sécurité intérieure
là aussi délai très bref entre la
promulgation de la loi relatif au
contrôle de le désarmer celle de
l'ordonance n'avait pas permis
d'intégrer les dispositions de cette loi
dans le nouveau code
l'article 6 temps notre habilité le
gouvernement a opéré l'extension du code
de la sécurité intérieure à la polynésie
française et aux autres territoires
d'outre-mer
le parlement pourra ainsi compte tenu de
la suppression de l'article 5 ratifié
l'ensemble du code de la sécurité
intérieure et ses adaptations ou
extensions autre mère lorsqu'il
examinera la future loi de ratification
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la commission des lois a voté très
majoritairement le texte qui est soumis
à notre haute assemblée nos concitoyens
et c'est logique sont inquiets des
menaces terroristes
les esprits ont été marqués par la
fermera le terrorisme frappe aveuglément
les récentes arrestations ont démontré
la vigilance et la compétence des
services en charge de ces missions aussi
leur courage et parfois leur abnégation
mais en la matière monsieur le ministre
vous avez su aussi faire le ménage
là où c'était nécessaire il faut une
forte volonté politique
l'état doit agir l'état doit rassurer
l'état doit être respectée cette volonté
monsieur le ministre cette volonté
politique vous l'avez vous le démontrer
chaque jour et les français y sont
sensibles préserver la sécurité de nos
concitoyens avec la sauvegarde des
libertés publiques
c'est le fondement même de la république
que nous aimons ainsi vous vous
inscrivez dans le droit fil d'un autre
ministre de l'intérieur georges
clemenceau qui sut dans les pires
épreuves toujours affirmer la puissance
de l'exécutif dans le respect des
libertés et vous ne serez pas étonné que
je conclus par une phrase qu'il prononça
ici même dans cet hémicycle au coeur de
la tourmente
il faut que l'éducation des hommes se
fasse elle n'est possible que par la
pratique nous avons le devoir de leur
assurer la liberté contre les
envahissements du pouvoir mais aussi
contre ceux de l'anarchie c'est ainsi
que j'invite le sénat a voté le texte de
la commission
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
maintenant cette tribune et à monsieur
le président de la commission
sénatoriale pour le contrôle de
l'application des lois
david assouline monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
je vais être plus actuels dans mon rôle
est - eric mais sans revenir sur les
points qui viennent d'être développées
j'ai souhaité intervenir dans ce débat
en ma qualité de président de la
commission pour le contrôle de
l'application des lois pour présenter
brièvement au sénat les travaux que nous
avons réalisés sur cette question je
soulignais que c'est une première depuis
la décision de constituer cette
commission que ce travail d'évaluation
puisse servir au débat en séance
plénière
comme vous le savez à la suite des
événements meurtriers de toulouse et de
montauban le précédent gouvernement
avait déposé sur le bureau du sénat le 4
mai un projet de loi sur le terrorisme
nous étions devant un cas d'école de ce
que nous voulons éviter dans la
fabrication de la loi quand le sénat
avait décidé de créer notre commission
la commission que je préside un
événement survient aussi tragique et
grave qu'il soit on annonce qu'on
réponse on va légiférer en trois
semaines sans prendre le temps de faire
le travail de contrôle et d'évaluation
partager des dispositifs existants et
pourtant multiples et complexes pour
juger de leur efficacité au regard même
de l'événement qui s'est produit
mais puisque l'urgence extrême était
envisagée malgré le fait que nous étions
konget de sessions plénières puisse pour
cause de campagne électorale
nous avons décidé de travailler dans cet
urgence pour offrir à tous nos collègues
mais aussi à nos concitoyens une
évaluation aussi précise que possible
des dispositifs existants et tant que
possible de leurs applications
le gouvernement avait annoncé son
intention d'aller vite notre commission
a donc dû travailler de la même façon et
en faire autant nous nous sommes donc
imposer des délais rapides en engageant
aussitôt un cycle d'auditions afin de
recenser et de suivre l'évolution des
textes successifs formant l'ossature de
la législation antiterroriste
depuis la loi fondatrice du 9 septembre
86 et si possible d'identifier les
forces et les faiblesses du dispositif
en vigueur telles qu'elles ressortaient
de la vie les personnes entendues dans
cette démarche la commission a fait
preuve de la plus grande transparence en
associant à ces auditions non seulement
et c'est normal et membre de la
commission des lois qui souhaitait y
assister et à chaque fois que possible
en ouvrant ses travaux à la presse parce
que nous considérons que dans un domaine
aussi spécialisé généralement méconnue
par l'opinion publique mais qui
véhiculent dans l'opinion publique
autant de fantasmes et de peur jouant
justifiait il me paraissait essentiel
que nos concitoyens mesure bien toutes
les difficultés de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et qu'il saisisse plus
concrètement comment le législateur
tente d'y répondre depuis 25 ans nous
avons ainsi entendu une dizaine des
meilleurs spécialistes de la question du
terrorisme aussi bien des universitaires
que des magistrats en poste sans oublier
le garde des sceaux de l'époque je salue
et qui est dans notre hémicycle monsieur
mercier
la présidente de la cnil et c'est pour
des raisons sur lesquelles il est
inutile de revenir ne vont pas été en
mesure d'entendre des plus hauts
responsables des services de
renseignement ce qui nous a pas permis
d'achever notre programme d'audition à
la culture de la gagne
accession et c'est pourquoi le rapport
l'état de nos travaux que j'ai publié
qui a pu servir aux travaux de notre
commission
avant cette loi n'est intervenue que
parce que après un projet de loi caduque
puisque la majorité présidentielle
inchangé
le gouvernement nous a fait savoir qu'il
était d'abord obligé de légiférer pour
pour non non non
pour permettre d'abord qu'une
législation en vigueur et qui arrivait à
terme fin 2012 comme le ministre nous
l'a expliqué et qui est absolument
nécessaire dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme puisse être reconduite et
légiférer aussi sur des aspects
effectivement envisagée par le précédent
gouvernement et qui ne posait pas de
problème comme le rapporteur nous l'a
expliqué
car en la matière il n'y a pas de place
pour des conflits et les postures
idéologiques mais de la place pour
l'efficacité dans une lutte qui doit
tous nous rassembler voilà dans ces
circonstances nouvelles ma première
préoccupation a été clos que ce travail
puisse être mis à la disposition comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de le rappeler le
rôle de la commission pour le contrôle
de l'application des lois n'est pas de
s'immiscer dans le travail législatif
incombant à la commission saisie sur le
fond du texte mais simplement de lui
fournir un état des lieux aussi précis
que possible de la législation en
vigueur et de la réalité de son
application
c'est ce que nous avons fait ce rapport
est à la disposition de tous les
sénateurs j'espère qu'il a pu être
regardée par le gouvernement qu'il a
achevé la préparation de cette loi et je
sais qu'il a été par notre rapporteur
je veux conclure sur ce qui a émergé de
ce travail que nous avions fait d'abord
un triple constat normatif le cadre
législatif actuel a été jugés dans
l'ensemble satisfaisants
c'est ce sont des propos comme ceux de
monsieur marc trévidic qui souligne que
la loi française qui donne tous les
pouvoirs nécessaires
tu ne paraît pas globalement sein de la
modifier en réaction à un fait divers ou
de monsieur françois heisbourg qui dit
nous disposons d'un arsenal juridique
très impressionnant que beaucoup de pays
nous envient
il n'est pas sûr que nous ayons besoin
d'autre chose que de quelques
adaptations il s'agit bien de cela dans
ce qui nous est présenté aujourd'hui
deuxième constat son application peut
soulever quelques difficultés mais
celles ci ne sont pas d'ordre sont plus
d'ordre pratique et organismes et
organisationnel que juridique
à la lumière de ce qui s'était passé
monsieur françoise mans nous a par
exemple dit que la dcr y n'étant pas
elle-même une direction générale qui
dépend de la dgpn qui vit une relative
du yen du fait de la révision générale
des politiques publiques
de surcroît la dcr est une institution
jeune et la fusion initiés de la 4 ans
de la dst et des renseignements généraux
rohr préfecture de police de services de
culture très différente n'est pas encore
complètement achevée
voilà des difficultés qui ne relèvent
pas de l'ordre de la loi mais bien de la
mise en pratique de des décisions et des
orientations que la loi permet trois le
terrorisme en 2012 n'est plus le même
qu'en 86 il ya eu des adaptations vrai
continuelle et dans la dernière décennie
la révolution de l'internet à obliger à
envisager à un rythme plus accéléré des
évolutions y compris dans la législation
et ça fait partie des réflexions qui
comprit qui nous sont proposées
aujourd'hui mais aussi le mode
opératoire a évolué monsieur samir en
garde je faisais pas de quelque chose
que l'on constate et qui a été révélée
encore plus de façon éclatante avec la
ferme ra et avec les dernières
arrestations aux attentats à la bombe
des années 90 et aux attentats suicide
des années 2000 ou en effet succédé des
agressions individuel affranchi du
groupe solidaire
his mathy à l'aide d'armes de poing et
c'est tous les intervenants ont mis
l'accent sur le rôle majeur joué
aujourd'hui par l'internet ce marc
trévidic nous a confié que depuis 2003
environ est apparue usages d'internet
pour la propagande et le recrutement
c'est la désormais que quasiment tout se
passe au moment où s'engage le débat en
séance publique pour conclure je tiens
simplement à faire part d'une
interrogation supplémentaires qui au
fond a toujours plus ou moins sous tendu
le témoignage de toutes les personnes
que nous avons entendu à notre
commission
face à une menace qui vise à affecter
profondément l'ordre social
comment concilier l'ofii l'efficacité de
la réponse pénale sans porter dans le
même temps une atteinte aux libertés
fondamentales
l'inventaire que nous avons réalisés
montrent bien le caractère
particulièrement délicat de l'exercice
de conciliation entre ces deux objectifs
pour le gros temps les textes adoptés
par le monde par le parlement depuis 86
ont doter notre pays d'un arsenal
législatif de plus en place certes mais
ne portant pas fondamentalement aux
libertés essentielles car les
dispositifs s'exerce sous le contrôle de
l'autorité judiciaire que la
constitution rend garante de la liberté
individuelle
ceci nous a été confirmée par le
témoignage de monsieur olivier christen
qui nous dit tout le dispositif anti
terroriste français s'il repose sur
plusieurs intervenants fonctionne autour
d'un même pivot central qui est le
dispositif judiciaire et cela a son
importance pour nous qui légiférons même
sur des choses et des événements aussi
délicat pour dire les choses plus
simplement le dispositif prend ce
français de lutte antiterroriste est une
législation exceptionnel mais pas une
législation d'exception
sans préjuger de la teneur définitive du
texte qui va sortir de nos travaux je
suis fier que la commission sénatoriale
pour le contrôle de l'application des
lois
et puis m 7,2 cette donnée fondamentale
en évidence et qu'elle est ainsi
apporter sa contribution à un débat dont
chacun mesure l'importance mais aussi la
discipline
merci chers collègues la parole et à
madame esther benbassa
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
comme vous le savez le présent projet de
loi succèdent où se substitue à un autre
déposée le 4 mai 2012 par notre collègue
michel mercier alors ministre de la
justice à la suite des tueries de
toulouse et montauban
il arrive un autre assemblée en
procédure accélérée cette fois par la
volonté du gouvernement de gauche
actuelle dans le contexte créé par la
ferme ra est alourdi par un nouveau
cycle d'événements heureusement moins
tragique
quoique profondément inquiétants avec
les récentes arrestations des membres
d'une cellule terroriste dans le ciel
dans le sillage de l' enquête menée à la
suite d'une attaque à la grenade lancée
dans une épicerie juive des sarcelles le
19 septembre
je ne le ferai pas ici l'historique
détaillée de la loi du 23 janvier 2006
dont les articles 3 6 et 9 ont tout et
ont été prorogés en 2008 jusqu'à la fin
de la présente année civile
c'est en effet dans un climat tendu que
nous avons engagées au sénat l'examen de
l'actuel projet de loi qui annette un
nouvel avatar comme l'imposent ce climat
et ce contexte de stress social et comme
l'imposent aussi mon attachement à
certains principes intangibles
je me dois de souligner mon rejet de
toute forme de terrorisme aveugle et ma
haine des fossoyeurs de toute
civilisation humaine auxquels nous
devons faire face
ainsi avant de développer toutes
considérations relatives aux éventuelles
dérives auxquelles pourrait conduire
certains articles de ce projet de loi et
pour éviter toute espèce de suspicion je
me permettrait de me placer sous les
ailes protectrices de d'un maître anne
éloquence mon excellent collègue et ami
jean pierre sueur dont le dévouement
aux intérêts de la nation n'est plus à
démontrer quand on vient d'arriver au
sénat comme moi ce n'est pas la lune une
prudence superflu ainsi s'exprime et il
en décembre 2005 lors des débats
entourant le vote de la loi d'origine
je le cite la lutte contre le terrorisme
nécessite le concours de tous les élus
de la république qui ne doivent pas
ménagé leur soutien aux gouvernements
quels qu'ils soient car nous devons
lutter de toutes nos forces
quand ses pieds la négation de la
civilisation et de la démocratie
ils ajouté d'un même élan la question
qui nous est posée est de savoir dans
quelles conditions il est légitime de
prendre les mesures exceptionnelles qu
appelle nécessairement la lutte contre
le terrorisme et il continué nous
pensons que ces mesures sont
nécessairement exceptionnel les
conditions dans lesquelles elles doivent
être prises appelle une attention toute
particulière
personne ne saurait rien à redire à la
sagesse de ses mots fixé dans la toile
du sénat et moi - que personne si nous
devons mener la lutte contre le fléau
dont nous parlons aujourd'hui nous ne
devons pourtant pas le faire à n'importe
quel prix et surtout pas en cédant sans
réfléchir à la pression de l'événement
monsieur sarkozy par l'intermédiaire de
son ministre de la justice réagisse et
en mai à la ferme ra il ne faudrait pas
à monsieur le ministre que nous donnions
le sentiment de simplement réagir à la
sphère de sarcelles et de relancer un
mécanisme déjà utilisé hier pour assurer
les français ce souci de rassurer en
guimet est certes en lui-même légitime
veillon néanmoins à éviter de donner le
sentiment de produire une simple
disposition d'affichage
si votre projet de loi monsieur le
ministre reprend certaines mesures
figurant déjà dans celui de monsieur
mercier il en réduit toutefois le
contenu à trois volets seulement le
dépouillant d'un certain nombre de
dispositions il n'en reprend pas moins
les articles 3 6 et 9 de la loi de 2006
demandé par monsieur sarkozy lui même
alors locataire qu'on vous aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre de la place beauvau
or la question que peut et sans doute
doit se poser tout citoyen et celle ci
pourquoi les dispositions votées en 2006
prorogé en 2008 n'ont elles pas suffi à
nous protéger d'un mohamed merah
pourtant connu par les services de
police
de même pourquoi les terroristes
présumés de la cellule de torcy 12
arrêtées dont 5 libéré après une longue
garde à vue
non ils étaient repérés qu'après la
lancer de grenade acer sa selle un acte
qui en d'autres circonstances aurait pu
se révéler beaucoup plus ma fille est
qu'ils ne l'a été
les mesures de 2006 avait été proposé
comme expérimentale et non définitive
après qu'il y est eu mort d'hommes et
d'enfants
est il utile de multiplier des
dispositions dont l'efficacité ne semble
pas démontrée et qui s'ajoute à
l'arsenal déjà existante de dispositions
de loi de lutte contre le terrorisme
en ce qui le concerne le groupe
écologiste demande d'une part que la
prorogation soit limité à décembre 2014
au lieu de décembre 2015 et qu'un
rapport détaillé d'évaluation soit
dressé avant toute nouvelle prorogation
un rapport de ce type
élaboré par les députés eric diard et
julien dray je crois socialiste elle en
dit en 2008 à la veille de la
programmation de 2008 ne concluait-il
pas qu'il ne fallait pas je cite sous le
coup d'une sorte de fatalisme juridique
et sous la pression d'hypothétiques
menace considéré que les dispositions
temporaire celle des articles 3 6 9 de
cette loi doivent être prolongées ou
plus encore être définitivement entériné
fin de citation tant que le monde
s'attaquera pas aux causes profondes de
l'émergence d'un terrorisme désormais
endogène et aux racines de l'engagement
de certains jeunes de nos quartiers y
compris de récents convertis à l'islam
dans les rangs d'un islamisme
destructeur tant que l'on continuera à
clamer les principes d'une laïcité tout
théorique sans vouloir le prendre la
mesure exacte des formes contemporaines
de retour de retour au religieux
tant que l'on ne se donnera pas les
moyens d'inventer des solutions
pratiques et non de pur principe à
l'école en prison dans la vie de tous
les jours et c'est tant que l'on ne
développera pas à nouveau dans les zones
sensibles
une police de proximité auxiliaire
indispensable pour cerner à temps et
pour prévenir le basculement de certains
de la délinquance dans une forme de
radicalité religieuse pouvant mener au
terrorisme tant que l'on fermera les
yeux sur le grippage de notre
l'ascenseur social et sur l'abandon de
nos quartiers populaires on pourra
promulguer toutes les lois qu'on voudra
sans jamais être assurée qu'elle suffise
à nous protéger
sur le long terme des phénomènes qui
nous préoccupe aujourd'hui le projet de
loi que nous examinons concours
certainement à la lutte contre le
terrorisme mais il doit aussi respecter
les libertés individuelles qui sont le
socle même de notre démocratie
sans chercher à provoquer une vaine
polémique je dois rappeler pourtant que
la gauche s'était opposé en 2006 et en
2008 aux dispositions des articles 3 6
et 9 dont le présent projet de loi
demande dans son article 1er la
provocation jusqu'à fin 2015 elle est
jugée alors liberticide
elle avait également dénoncé
exquis loin de s'en tenir à la
prévention et à la répression répression
du terrorisme contenait des mesures
visant à lutter contre la délinquance
ordinaire et l'immigration irrégulière
et à élargir les possibilités de
contrôle aux frontières
hormis l'émotion provoquée provoquée par
la ferme et rats et les récentes
arrestations
on ne voit pas ce qui seulement quatre
ans plus tard devrait fondamentalement
modifier cette position
ce n'est pas nous écologistes qui feront
un procès en inconstance nos amis
socialistes
ainsi le veulent ainsi le veulent
ainsi le veulent sans doute la politique
est la raison d'état nous ne
présenterons pas non plus aucun
amendement pour la suppression de la fiq
premier dans le contexte actuel un
amendement qui pourrait être interprétée
comme décalé en revanche nous
demanderons la réduction de la durée de
prorogation au 31 décembre 2014
les articles 3 et cadre du projet de loi
que nous examinons ont trait aux droits
des étrangers et touche au code
régissant leur entrée et leur séjour il
modifie l'article l 521 2-2 du ceseda en
assouplissant la procédure devant la
commission par l'ajout d'un alinéa
si la commission n'a pas émis son avis
sur l'expulsion dans un délai d'un mois
celui ci est réputé rendu malgré
l'amendement du rapporteur
cet article vise à pallier les carences
d'une commission qui statue en général
dans des délais bien supérieur en un
mois empêchant ainsi l'administration de
se prononcer elle entend difficile la
mise en oeuvre des mesures d'expulsion
en fait cet article contourne les
garanties entourant les procédures
d'expulsion ainsi l'administration
pourra-t-elle statut et librement s'il
ya carence de la commission
pourquoi cette précipitation votre
l'intention ne peut être simplement j'en
suis sûr monsieur le ministre de pouvoir
expulser des étrangers avec plus de
facilité pourquoi dès lors donné tant de
liberté à l'administration
on sait que la gauche ait toujours à
coeur de l'enfant forcé les prérogatives
de la commission et que c'est la droite
qui les a limités
cela est même marqué dans leurs rapports
faits par les collaborateurs socialiste
du du groupe socialiste au sénat
autres temps autres moeurs dirons nous
nous le groupe écologie nous plaçons
dans la tradition de cette même gauche
aujourd'hui majoritaires à laquelle nous
appartenons nous déposerons un
amendement supprimant la possibilité
pour l'administration de statuer en cas
de carence de la commission d'expulsion
renforçant ainsi les prêts aux plaines
locative de cette dernière ainsi
rempliront nous notre rôle de mémoire
politique des socialistes dans une
continuité à la fois libre est
profondément soucieuse des droits de
l'homme et de la femme ajouterais-je
pour conclure je dirais que d'autres
votre finale dépendra du sort réservé
par cette auguste assemblée à nos
amendements
s'ils sont rejetés nous choisirons
l'abstention
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant aux présidents jean jacques
hyest
monsieur le président monsieur madame le
garde des sceaux ce ministre de
l'intérieur sur le président de la
commission des lois
mes chers collègues à monsieur le
ministre votre déclaration de cet après
midi ne peux je vous le dis et je
l'espère que rencontré l'adhésion de
toute la représentation nationale
néanmoins je souhaiterais revenir un
instant sur la contradiction qui se
manifestent devant nous et dans ma
collègue même basse a été l'illustration
si l'on se réfère notamment à la
position des sénateurs socialistes et
communistes
et encore nous ne bénéficions pas d'un
groupe d europe écologie les verts sur
la joie de 2006 soit ifa la lutte contre
le terrorisme
c'est les lectures c'est toujours
intéressant quand on a une carrière
longue de parlementaires il faut
toujours faire attention à ce qu'on dit
sonné repris par son passé je me réjouis
monsieur le ministre que l'appréciation
échanger et que l'on reconnaisse enfin
d'utilité des mesures que vous qualifiez
à l'époque mars dernier sert dans un
autre rôle de précipiter voyez monsieur
le mini je vais pas vous reprocher la
procédure accès ce qu'elle est parfois
utile et on sait très bien qu'il faut
décider avant le 31 décembre de la
prolongation
en fait obligatoire de la loi de 2006 si
le motif pour lequel d'ailleurs nous ne
souhaitons pas et la commission étaient
unanimes ratifier l'ordonnancé comme
vous savez le travail est parfait
l'administration de tous ceux qui
collaborent à l' élaboration de la
codification mais notre expérience assez
nous a prouvé que le parlement si on lui
demande de ratifier c'est quand même que
ça doit avoir un sens et on a intérêt à
regarder très près
si elle part cette cohérence alors vous
nous confirmer aujourd'hui que les
textes précédents était utile était de
bon sens et vous même vous en proposer
d'autres
notre collègue françois rebsamen
président du groupe socialiste il a il
dénonçait pourtant un projet de loi
décidé dans l'urgence mal préparé mal
ficelé sans évaluation préalable et de
la fia eux et ceux s'inquiétait de la
fiabilité d'efficacité de son contenu et
bien pourtant on reprend une partie des
mesures alors annoncées par nicolas
sarkozy est portée par le projet du
garde des sceaux
alors monsieur le ministre nous avait
annoncé un projet de loi le 15 septembre
bus après le 15 septembre
manifestation devant l'ambassade
américaine à paris je ne me permettrais
pas comme par le passé de juger la
méthode du gouvernement qui dans les
membres refusé jusque là paraît-il la
réactivité une émotion collective
non mais je ne voulus mais c'est ce que
vous faisiez avant moi je ne vous le
reproche pas je ne vous dirai pas que
cette annonce la suite une émotion
collective propagées par des médias de
masse
je ne dirais même pas que vous souhaitez
envoyer un message à l'opinion française
et affirmer votre présence sur front de
la lutte contre le terrorisme
car comme vous je ne vous le dis paris
car comme vous je considère la menace
terroriste comme particulièrement
préoccupante en reprenant à votre cote
le fond d'un texte qui était proposé un
autre gouvernement dit de droite
et pourtant vous avez s'étaient
combattus pendant les nombreuses
semaines de campagne prétend pas par
vous monsieur le ministre et par
beaucoup de vos amis vous imaginez
certainement des français
courant s'interroger sur un changement
complet de position mais il est heureux
et ce n'est pas le seul cas si l'on se
reporte au débat sur le pacte européen
de stabilité la semaine dernière non
mais on peut changer d'avis quand on est
responsable on peut changer d'avis c'est
tout après la fermera je me souviens que
lorsque nicolas sarkozy avait envisagé
une loi prévoyant une surveillance des
connexions internet
on avait critiqué le populisme pénal
pour notre mémoire collective je
souhaiterais bien entendu revenir un
instant sur le texte courageux de notre
collègue michel mercier alors garde des
sceaux avait présenté qu'il ne remettait
pas en cause la jce yes sur actuelle
mais l'améliorer
je suis très heureux de votre présence
madame la garde des sceaux parce que je
craignais que comme par le passé
les détections terrorisme a fabriqué
uniquement ministère de l'intérieur
ouais je vous le dis je suis honnête
mais non c'est d'une collaboration qui a
toujours existé entre la chancellerie et
le ministère de l'intérieur
ce quand même quand il s'agit de droit
pénal il vaut mieux que l'ags la
chancellerie soit concerné alors ce
texte proposait quatre nouvelles mesures
donner des moyens supplémentaires aux
magistrats et aux enquêteurs notamment
en matière de perquisitions d'écoutés
l'infiltration pénaliser la consultation
habituelle sans motif légitime des sites
internet on en parlera tout leur
pénaliser ceux qui se rendent dans des
camps d'entraînement à des fins
terroristes
ça peut rentrer dedans
dans certains cas et appliquez enfin
directive européenne ou plutôt une
décision cadre européenne instaurant un
délit d'instigateur d'actes terroristes
je traiterai faire ce jeu souhaité faire
ce rappel
afin que nous ayons tout comme nos
concitoyens conscient des similitudes et
des différences qui nous anime depuis
1986 je m'en souviens j'étais jeune
député et c'est une des premières des
premières lois que nous avons votée sous
la législature qui était interrompu dans
parce qu'il y avait déjà les drm menace
terroriste
je suis délégué toute la vague
d'attentats les années 70 les la france
a pris conscience du caractère
spécifique de cette menace et a
perpétuellement fait évoluer sa
législation en fonction des évolutions
des modes opératoires et de l'émergence
de nouvelles menaces
vous l'avez tout à fait décrite monsieur
le ministre tout à l'heure les
évolutions nous avons toujours veillé à
maintenir en équilibre constant entre
l'attribution à la puissance vie de
prérogatives renforcées nécessaires à la
sécurité collective et à la préservation
des libertés publiques
d'ailleurs le rapport de la commission
d'application des lois
le président à souligner trois ans c'est
dommage j'aurais eu pour une fois
j'aurais dit quelque chose de presque
aimable à son égard
voilà le rapport de la commission
d'application des droits relatifs à la
sécurité intérieure et la lutte contre l
humoriste dont je peux simplement
regretter qu'il ait été publié dans
l'urgence et un rapport forcément
provisoire est insuffisant de mon point
de vue la fin triple constat intéressant
néanmoins en précisant que le cadre
législatif actuel est satisfaisant pour
tous ceux qui ont voté les lois
successives
on est heureux de savoir ce que certains
disaient que c'était pas moyen du tout
même si son application rencontre
quelques difficultés dans pratique nosy
juridique
je pense notamment monsieur le ministre
j'y reviendrai à l'article 6 de la loi
de 2006 et et préconise donc des
évolutions législatives différents tops
de l'évolution des méthodes et moyens
terrorise je crois que nous en sommes
tous d'accord ce qui m'amène à avoir des
différences qui périssent entre nous au
travers ce texte c'est comme l'a rappelé
un bon spécialiste le crois qu'on peut
tout le monde le reconnaît françois
heisbourg conseiller spécial de la
fondation pour la recherche stratégique
lors de ses auditions le rapporteur
l'adaptation passe notamment sur une
plus grande attention accordée à
internet
alors internet est effectivement mais
c'est impossible d'aller chercher sur
internet
les connexions qui peuvent avoir le lien
avec le terrorisme mais aussi sans doute
et on en discutera la création d'un
nouveau délit de consultation sur des
sites internet
e comme cela existe déjà d'ailleurs à
l'article 227-23 du code pénal nous
souhaitons aussi réprimer la propagation
et l'apologie d'idéologies extrémistes
qui constitue la provocation actes de
terrorisme et l'apologie sida en créant
un dédit figurants non plus dans la loi
de 80 sur la liberté de la presse et
dans le code pénal
je crois que c'est un débat toute façon
générale les travaux de la commission
des lois ce matin permettront peut-être
de faire aboutir un consensus en ce qui
concerne ses
question ce que problème de prescription
de trois mois forcément dans la loi de
1881 est-ce qu'on peut accepter un délai
de prescription plus long dans la loi de
80 sans doute et surtout est ce que on
peut aussi de procéder à une détention
provisoire c'est la question c'est
pourquoi nous avons souhaité nous avions
souhaité envisager un délit particulier
enfin il est important pour nous la
décision cadre européenne de novembre
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance nous y
reviendrons plus largement dans nos
éditions de 19h et de 22h à suivre
preuve par 3 l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat